>> I'm actually going to discuss the topic
of the Middle East and
what's headed in the future for the Arab leaders
and leaders worldwide
are working on the Middle East.
Maybe there has been some focus and some realizing
of the importance of
the issue in Jordan and a little bit regionally,
however,
internationally and many in the US, it hasn't
been as expected.
What is really needed on this aspect is needed
to take quick actions in
this regard as we truly need that we, as a
community.
There's no quick action in that aspect within
the next couple of
months, there will be will be a big challenge
to the whole continuing
of the peace process.
Now in the regard the issue of the Palestine/Israeli
topic and whether
it is important or not -- yes, it is actually
the most important.
And that needs to get addressed.
And if you look at any other issues related
to the region they will
all -- this topic will all always crop up
as the critical one.
So my advice and my recommendation as a young
global leader, that this
should be addressed as a critical solution
in order to be able to
realize the prosperity and the sustainability
whether economically or
politically in the next years.
Thank you.